Necesitamos encontrar el vértice y el eje de simetría de esta gráfica y bueno creo que el punto más importante
de este vídeo es que entiendas qué es el eje de simetría y el vértice de una parábola.
Así que para refrescarnos un poco en estos dos conceptos
vamos a ver si la parábola se ve más o menos así. El vértice sería el punto que está más abajo de la gráfica es
decir, su punto mínimo ahora si la parábola abre hacia abajo como ésta,
entonces el vértice es su punto
máximo, o el punto que está más alto, y el eje de simetría es aquella línea en la cual puede reflejar la parábola en ella,
y que sea simétrica ese es justo el eje de simetría.
Es decir la parte de la derecha es el reflejo de la parte izquierda de la parábola a lo largo de este eje, y en
una manera general, para poder saber si mi parábola abre hacia arriba o abre hacia abajo es que pasa lo siguiente.
Esta tiene un coeficiente positivo al lado de la "x" cuadrada,
mientras que se abre hacia abajo en el término de la "x" cuadrada tenemos un coeficiente
negativo pero, bueno vamos a ver esto con mayor detalle, así que trabajemos con esto. Y por ahora
lo que quiero que hagamos, es crear intuición de cómo se resuelven estos problemas y qué es lo que vamos a hacer con esta
función. Por que de hecho hay una fórmula y tú podrías aplicar la fórmula pero no saber de dónde viene todo esto.
Así que lo importante y en lo que me quiero basar en este vídeo, es que vayamos trabajando en la forma de la intuición,
en cómo se resuelve en este tipo de problemas y entiendas
perfectamente bien qué es lo que está sucediendo.
Me voy a fijar en esta ecuación "y" es igual a -2x cuadrada más 8x más 8 y lo primero que voy
a hacer es factorizar -2 un -2 que multiplica ¿A quién? Bueno multiplica a "x" cuadrada -4x
y hasta acá hasta el final, voy a poner este -4 y lo estoy poniendo hasta acá
por que lo que voy a es hacer aquí es completar el binomio cuadrado perfecto.
Es decir me voy a fijar en la expresión "x" cuadrada -4x
y voy a completar de aquí, el binomio cuadrado perfecto y para esto voy a decir que número le tengo que agregar
a esta expresión, para que sea un binomio cuadrado perfecto y es 4. Si tú te fijas en el número que está al lado de la
"x", me queda -4 y - 4 dividido entre 2 es -2
elevado al cuadrado, me da 4. Con lo que veo que esto es un binomio
cuadrado perfecto pero yo no puedo agregar 4 de la nada, sé que necesito este 4 pero, no lo puedo agregar nada más por que sí.
Recuerda que lo que tengo que hacer es restar 4 para que la igualdad se mantenga. Con esto va a seguir
equilibrada mi función y entonces no ha pasado nada o al menos nada grave. Y bueno "x" cuadrada -4x más 4, lo estoy
poniendo así por que esto es un binomio al  cuadrado perfecto.
Esto es lo mismo que "x"  -2 elevado al cuadrado entonces, debemos escribirlo "x" -2 elevado
esto al cuadrado. Date cuenta que de aquí sale el "x" cuadrada -4x más 4
y bueno después tengo -2 que multiplica esto y al final tengo -4 -4 lo cual me da -8.
Fíjate que no había hecho nada con este -4 y este -4, y bueno ya que tengo esto ahora lo que voy a
hacer es distribuir de nuevo el -2.
Primero lo factoricé y ahora lo voy a distribuir, para que me quede mucho más clara esta expresión y me queda -2
que multiplica primero a "x" -2 al cuadrado y después menos por menos me da más 8 por 2
16 y entonces, esta expresión de aquí es exactamente lo mismo o es equivalente,
a decir que "y" es igual a -2 que multiplica a "x" -2 elevado al cuadrado más
16 y bueno ¿ Para que hice todo esto? Por que aquí vamos a poder encontrar una manera mucho más sencilla el vértice.
Fíjate bien lo primero que quiero que observes es que "x" -2 al cuadrado, como es una cantidad que está elevando al cuadrado, siempre es
positivo y ahora date cuenta de esto, si yo a este número
positivo que siempre es positivo, lo multiplicó por algo negativo, por este -2 entonces me da que esto, siempre es negativo.
Esto es muy importante
- 2 por "x" -2 elevado al cuadrado es siempre
negativo y por lo tanto, entre más grande me tome un número y lo eleve al cuadrado y después le multiplique por - 2 me va
a salir un número mucho más
negativo, y si este número mucho más negativo le sumo 16, pues entonces me da pie para preguntarme
¿Cuál es el valor que puede tomar esta función que me de mi valor máximo?
Y bueno si te das cuenta, mi valor máximo es cuando esto de aquí valga 0,
por que si esto de aquí vale 0, 0 al cuadrado es 0 por -2 me da 0
y el valor más grande que puede obtener es
16 es decir, el valor más grande de esta función se cumple cuando "x"  -2 es igual a 0, por que en cualquier otro caso
lo que voy a obtener
son números más pequeños, por que estoy restando a 16 y bueno "x" -2 es igual a 0 si "x" es igual a 2.
Y entonces si "x" vale 2 entonces 2 -2 es 0 al cuadrado es 0 -2 es 0 y entonces obtengo que "y" vale 16,
y esto quiere decir que acabo de encontrar mi vértice de esta parábola.
Mi vértice de esta parábola está en el punto "x" igual a 2 "y"  igual a 16, en el punto 2,16
es el vértice de mi parábola por que estoy encontrando el punto
de esta función en el cual tengo una propiedad muy importante, es el punto más alto de esta función,
cualquier otro punto que yo me tome en mi gráfica de esta función, va a ser menor que el vértice de esta parábola.
Y bueno una vez que ya tenemos el vértice de esta parábola, sería muy bueno graficarlo así que aquí tengo 1, 2, voy a suponer que este
este es el 2 y después 2, 4, 6, 8, 10, 12, 14, 16.
Estoy parado justo aquí, aquí va a ser
mi vértice de mi parábola y entonces si este es mi vértice de mi parábola, ya sabemos cuál es el eje de simetría de esta parábola.
Es justo este mismo, si es una parábola que abre hacia abajo, entonces aquí tengo mi eje de simetría.
Y bueno solamente por curiosidad y para quitarnos de la duda de cómo se va a ver la gráfica de esta parábola, vamos a buscar
otros dos puntos para poderla graficar. Si yo pongo que "x" vale 0, me va a salir 0, 0 y 8.
Es decir cuando "x" vale 0 ,"y" vale 8 que estamos en este eje, y va a ser justo aquí y ahora darte cuenta de
lo siguiente, como tenemos simetría con este eje de simetría,
entonces también tenemos este otro punto y ya se ve claramente que así tiene que ser mi parábola ya la podemos graficar.
Perfecto ya aquí tengo mi parábola y bueno en un
principio en este vídeo, yo te mencionaba de que había una fórmula para encontrar de una manera mucho más sencilla
el valor de "x" del vértice de nuestra parábola.
Es que alguna vez vimos que el valor de "x" del vértice de una parábola, lo podemos sacar como -"b" entre 2a
y pues sería muy bueno comprobar que en efecto llegamos al mismo resultado.
Si el vértice está
en el valor de "x" cuando "x" vale -"b" entre 2a pues entonces lo único que hay que hacer es sustituir los valores
de "a" y "b".
Entonces que nos quedaría si aplicamos a esta misma parábola, pues que "x" va a ser igual a -"b" pero en esta ocasión "b" vale
8 entre 2 veces "a", entre 2 por el valor de "a" que en este caso es -2
2 por -2 y bueno esto a cuánto es equivalente,
-8 entre -4 y menos entre menos me da más, 8 entre 4 me da 2  y entonces
ya acabamos y está perfecto, por que es justo el mismo valor que encontramos al resolver este ejercicio de una manera mucho más
intuitiva. El vértice están en el 2,16.